meantime Democratic senator Al Franken
plans a major announcement on the Senate
floor today he could resign after
repeated sexual harassment accusations
against him 35 of the 47 other
Democratic caucus senators have asked
him to step down frankenz office tweeted
last night that he hasn't made a final
decision at least eight women now accuse
him of unwanted contact Nancy Cordes is
on Capitol Hill with the latest Nancy
good morning good morning sources tell
us that Franklin is wrestling with this
decision despite the clear message from
most of his Democratic Senate colleagues
in fact the Senate's Democratic leader
Chuck Schumer spoke to his good friend
Al Franken several times yesterday
urging him to step down I hope that
he'll do the right thing Democratic
women made it clear on Wednesday what
they think is the right thing to do I do
not feel that he should continue to
serve they were followed by their male
colleagues on the left and right was
there something that was a tipping point
for you the first accusation came last
month from radio host Lee aunt Whedon
who said Franken forcefully kissed her
and appeared to grope her as she slept
in 2006 what that was you sitting there
what if that was your daughter or your
sister or your mom is that funny then a
series of women claimed he grabbed their
buttocks or breasts when they posed for
pictures with him I can't say I haven't
done that frankenz quasi denials left
his colleagues unsatisfied those are
instances that I do not remember the
final straw came yesterday morning when
a former Democratic staffer told
POLITICO Franken tried to forcibly kiss
her in 2006 then yesterday afternoon
Atlantic writer Tina Dupuy said Franken
groped her in 2009 it's time for Senator
Franken to step down the past three
weeks have been painful for Democrats
the former comedian was a popular party
luminary known for his dogged
questioning I'm just asking if you're
challenging my figures I would ask that
you get your figures straight and even
considered a potential presidential
contender in 2020
Franken categorically denied one of
yesterday's allegation but by then I'm
told that many of his Democratic
colleagues had already made up their
minds and it is highly unusual Gale for
a lawmaker to stick around once their
own party members have told them it's
time to go
it does appear quite difficult thank you
very much Nancy